we will get to those stories in just a
moment but first here at 11 the pandemic
and
all that comes with it can be so hard on
our kids
tonight we want to talk to you about
resources that you can use
right now that could help that's right
we spent time today listening into a
virtual seminar
hosted in part by a parent who's been
through a nightmare losing a child to
suicide
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joining us now with more
madison
yes probably the most impactful part of
tonight's seminar was hearing from the
teens themselves
and other people that have dealt with
the issue firsthand here in the valley
i struggled with depression
i would say my freshman year of high
school
it was just a very very sad time in my
life where i didn't know
where i was going i didn't know what i
was doing valerie just one of several
students who wanted to share their
stories at tonight's seminar
they wanted their chance to shine the
spotlight on their struggles
we do already have this preconceived
notion of what
mental health is and what mental illness
is and what
the bottom line of it is and joining in
on the conversation
reggie burton he lost his son to suicide
in 2017
and spoke to parents about simple
changes they can make to help their kids
i think the things that parents can do
to
make that conversation about mental
health less awkward
is changing the conversation ever so
slightly from
you know how's it going to how are you
feeling
it's all a part of the well-beings tour
a 34-city webinar that connects
communities in efforts to address
stigmas
and raise awareness about mental health
and well-being tonight's discussion also
included information about access to
resources
and one thing that we do have in this
state that is available
is our amazing mobile crisis team that's
across this whole state
they can actually be in a home with a
youth in about 30 minutes in the las
vegas valley i think that
the mental health surge grew faster
than maybe the city anticipated um
and you know i think for a while it
wasn't a priority
and now we're seeing how important
mental health is in all communities
now as for that mobile crisis team we'll
have two numbers up on our website for
you to call
someone to help reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now